[Musique]
Geneviève dariosei bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue le président de la République
se rend aujourd'hui dans un lycée
professionnel est-ce un domaine où
l'inclusion des personnes handicapées
est encore à promouvoir oui je crois
les lycées professionnels voilà sont des
lieux de formation absolument essentiels
et le président de la République
souhaite vraiment développer
l'enseignement professionnel afin de le
rendre plus plus efficace et surtout
qu'il intéresse plus de jeunes et bien
entendu que nous devons être attentifs à
ce qu'il soit accessible aux jeunes en
situation de handicap c'est-à-dire des
machines équipées des accès facilités
c'est de l'argent à mettre c'est des
bâtiments à refaire alors bien entendu
il y a l'accessibilité au sens des des
équipements des bâtiments toutes ces
choses là qui en général sont réalisés
ou sont en cours de réalisation c'est
l'état d'esprit surtout mais c'est
l'accessibilité aussi de l'enseignement
avec des pédagogies adaptées si c'est
nécessaire et puis avec effectivement
des outils particuliers pour les
personnes en situation de handicap qui
leur permettent de suivre l'enseignement
avec leur handicap est-ce que la rentrée
scolaire est universitaire a été aussi
inclusive que vous le souhaitiez elle a
été inclusive alors ce n'est jamais
assez puisque il y a toujours des
familles qui se plaignent de ne pas
avoir de solutions ce qui est une
réalité peut par rapport au nombre
d'enfants inclus dans les écoles 430000
enfants en situation de handicap qui
sont rentrés qui ont fait leur rentrée
scolaire c'est quand même considérable
quelques milliers qui eux n'ont quelques
centaines qui n'ont pas qui n'ont
peut-être pas de solution donc bien
entendu qu'il faut que nous poursuivions
et ces personnes là d'ailleurs et ses
parents là ils sont moi je leur
conseille vraiment il y a un numéro en
numéro unique le 0 800
et qui leur permet d'appeler sur cette
plateforme pour trouver une solution en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
l'ambition c'est de laisser personne
sans réponse les choses se mettent en
route progressivement de plus en plus
d'enfants sont inclus dans les écoles et
je pense que c'est un à la fois
fort pour l'éducation nationale qui qui
doit recevoir tous les enfants parce que
chaque enfant a droit à une éducation et
puis important pour les familles aussi
de pouvoir et bien de pouvoir sentir que
leur enfant a l'accès à un accès à
l'éducation et à l'école avec tous les
autres est-ce que nous manquons toujours
de personnel pour accompagner les élèves
handicapés qui ont besoin d'être
assistés alors aujourd'hui dans cette
rentrée il y a eu
4000 AEH ce sont des assistants
d'éducation pour ces enfants handicapés
supplémentaires par rapport à l'année
d'avant donc nous en sommes à plus de
130 000 aesh
il manque peut-être des avsa ce qui est
certain c'est que la réflexion doit être
dans l'évaluation est-ce que chaque
enfant avec un handicap a besoin d'un
aesh non
il y a une palette d'outils c'est à dire
il faut pour certains un matériel
spécifique il faut pour d'autres une
pédagogie spécifique enfin pour certains
il faut effectivement un accompagnement
humain donc c'est tout cela qui est à
considérer dans son ensemble et que nous
avons à décliner à chaque rentrée
scolaire ce qui est un véritable
challenge pour l'éducation nationale qui
est en charge de cette mise en oeuvre
tous les ans on engage une procédure de
validation des acquis pour les personnes
qui aident des proches notamment des
personnes très âgées est-ce qu'on peut
faire la même chose pour ce qui est des
handicapés absolument enfin ça vient
d'être proposé
par le ministre de du travail c'est que
les validations des Acquis de
l'Expérience puissent être accessible
aux personnes aidantes donc aidant les
personnes âgées mais aussi les personnes
handicapées et au procédant afin que
l'expérience qu'ils ont accumulés en
étant
au contact et aux chevets ou en
proximité de leurs parents en situation
de handicap ou de dépendance leur comté
effectivement dans l'obtention
potentielle d'un diplôme il faut mettre
les compétences avant les incapacités
avez-vous dit nous sommes en période de
pénurie d'emploi sans cynisme aucun
est-ce que ça n'aide pas les handicapés
à rentrer dans le marché du travail mais
je crois qu'il faut les aider parce que
c'est leur souhait leur souhait c'est
d'être inclus dans la vie
de la société et le travail fait partie
de la vie de la société donc oui notre
trop souvent est trop longtemps vu le
handicap comme une incapacité moi je
pense qu'il faut évaluer les compétences
de chaque personne en situation de
handicap et je peux vous assurer que ils
en ont beaucoup elles annoncent beaucoup
leur compétences les évaluer adapter des
formations par rapport à ses compétences
et aux besoins du marché du travail et
leur permettre d'avoir un accès à
l'emploi est-ce que le Conseil national
de la refondation peut vous aider à
faire progresser la cause des handicapés
le handicap et les handicapés et le
sujet du handicap est transversal il est
dans toutes nos politiques donc pour
tous les ministères et avec
Jean-Christophe combe nous sommes nous
veillons à ce que justement chacun de
nos collègues s'emparent de cette
politique dans tout ce qu'il met en
œuvre alors bien entendu que ce sera
également un sujet et d'ailleurs les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
représentées dans ce conseil national de
la refondation parce que leur sujet est
transversal mais doit être traitée
également alors la location adulte
handicapé sera décongivalisée ça a été
voté mais pourquoi attendre presque un
an encore pour pour l'appliquer cette
mesure
on se rend pas bien compte mais il y a
souvent des contingences à la fois des
contingences juridiques et des
contingences techniques actuellement
nous sommes en ordre de bataille pour
mettre en œuvre un décret ce décret doit
apparaître fin décembre pourquoi il faut
tant de temps pour mettre en œuvre et
écrire un décret tout simplement parce
que si nous appliquons la
décongivalisation
comme elle a été totalement brutalement
il y a 45000 personnes qui sont
perdantes elles vont gagner moins avec
cette déconjugalisation donc c'est un
biais
important donc nous devons adapter ce
décret afin que justement alors c'est
très technique je vais pas rentrer dans
les détails parce que je vous avoue que
c'est très très technique mais
l'objectif politique c'est que personne
ne perde qu'il n'y a que des personnes
qui puissent rentrer dans le système ben
pas des personnes qui en sortent à cause
de cette loi donc nous travaillons sur
ce décret qui paraîtra vers le milieu du
mois de décembre et ensuite il faut une
mise en oeuvre par la Caisse
d'allocations familiales et qui doit
construire une architecture
numérique
afin de pouvoir mettre en œuvre cet âge
déconjugués et ça demande à la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales de complètement
de d'inventer on va dire un système
numérique différent par rapport à celui
qui l'a actuellement parce que toutes
les prestations de la Caisse
d'Allocations familiale tiennent compte
des revenus de la famille la fin de vie
fera l'objet d'une convention citoyenne
c'est le souhait du président de la
République pour certains handicapés très
lourds renoncer à l'existence peut-être
une volonté les personnes handicapées
vont être concernées par ce débat on se
souvient bien sûr de l'affaire did
Vincent Humbert
écoutez aujourd'hui nous en sommes un
comité d'éthique qui va remettre son
rapport enfin au président de la
République le président de la République
doit mettre en oeuvre une consultation
citoyenne et puis de toutes les parties
prenantes je crois
qui devrait durer 6 mois et je crois que
le Président de la République
s'exprimera aujourd'hui là-dessus donc
je vais pas faire d'annonce avant lui
bien sûr parce que je n'ai pas les
annonces qu'il va qu'il va faire mais
bien sûr que c'est un sujet qui concerne
les personnes en situation de handicap
vous au fond de vous-même vous vous
dites la loi Claisse Leonetti est
suffisante ou vous vous dites le moment
est venu de la faire évoluer moi je
crois qu'il faut écouter la société il
faut écouter
les personnes en situation de handicap
il faut écouter
ce qui parle d'éthique c'est important
il faut voilà il faut écouter la société
je crois que cette convention citoyenne
est un bon moment pour que chacun puisse
dans son intimité se faire une idée la
loi léonét et là le mérite d'exister et
elle n'a pas toujours été appliquée au
niveau auquel elle aurait dû être
appliquée à référendum sur ce sujet
c'est envisager le président de la
confié hier à des journalistes c'est au
peuple de trancher à terme c'est un
sujet de société pourquoi pas bien sûr
autre sujet de société les retraites les
retraites seront déficitaires dans
quelques années analyse le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites est-ce qu'il
faut néanmoins précipiter la réforme on
évoque le la loi de finance de sécurité
sociale de cet automne pour faire passer
des mesures est-ce que ce n'est pas
mettre le feu aux poudres syndicales je
sais pas s'il faut précipiter les choses
mais depuis le temps que j'entends
parler de réforme des retraites on
précipiterait et visiblement on est dans
un mur budgétaire donc je crois qu'un
jour il faudra prendre des décisions qui
soient des décisions courageuses et
collectives avec peut-être deux
objectifs le premier bien c'est qu'on ne
touche pas aux pensions de retraite et
le deuxième c'est que on supplémentaire
donc le travail il faudra certainement
travailler plus longtemps je crois que
c'est du bon sens c'est que ça tout le
monde ne le comprend après quel est le
bon moment je ne suis pas en capacité de
vous le dire mais tout de suite il faut
en parler le modèle est vigilant sur ce
sujet depuis des années comme il l'est
sur les comptes publics en général
et bien oui les comptes publics c'est
quand même un sujet essentiel bien sûr
on a bien vu avec le covid la dépense
publique a beaucoup augmenté mais
heureusement que nous avons porté les
mesures qui ont été portées pour
soutenir l'économie française et
soutenir les Français pendant la période
covid là nous avons l'inflation donc
encore des soutiens mais il est certain
que le déficit public
est à terme et à long terme quelque
chose à regarder comme inquiétant
et qu'il nous faut traiter avec le plus
grand sérieux donc voilà mais je me
semble que les Français comprennent ça
la majorité présidentielle serait
organise Renaissance le nouveau nom du
du parti lrem avec lancer là en fin de
semaine est-ce que le modem est à l'aise
dans cette majorité présidentielle je
crois
il me semble que le modem est un vrai
pilier de la majorité il a été pendant 5
ans en tout cas le reste et le restera
avec sa spécificité avec son ancrage
local avec ses élus ces élus mais oui le
modèle est une est vraiment un
pilier fort de cette majorité va leur
rester ce qui empêche la majorité de
pencher trop à droite peut-être
au fond de moi-même quand je regarde
évoluer les choses je me dis trop à
droite trop à gauche on est au centre
nous sommes tous au centre du centre
gauche au centre de droit et le modem
est bien à sa place dans cette dans
cette majorité une France qui reste à
peu près cent triste dans une Europe qui
elle va vers la droite la plus dure on
l'a vu en suédière on le verra en Italie
bientôt on voit l'inquiétude des peuples
qui se traduit le désarroi un petit peu
des peuples qui se traduit par cette
montée effectivement
de l'extrême droite des nationalismes
oui moi je trouve tout cela inquiétant
nous portons voilà nous portons des
valeurs humanistes qui nous semble
important de continuer à promouvoir
est-ce qu'au modem la réflexion s'ouvre
sur l'après François Bayrou
non il est là il était éteint bateau et
on n'est pas dans la guerre du
succession contrairement à beaucoup de
familles politiques nous sommes pas dans
la guerre de succession vous savez au
modem en fait je sais pas comment ça se
passe dans les autres parties parce que
je ne les ai pas fréquentés de
l'intérieur mais au modèle une chose est
sûre c'est que la parole est libre c'est
que chacun peut s'exprimer
et que chacun est entendu
considéré et tout ça me paraît
absolument essentiel donc c'est un c'est
vraiment un parti formidable Geneviève
darrieussec merci et bonne journée merci
à vous merci beaucoup Christophe Barbier
et demain matin à 7h45 votre invité sera
pire je vais porte-parole du Parti
socialiste